I'll reject nation Greg Alva Air Jordan
Ross from the cinematix YouTube channel
make sure to check out his channel
people I'm subscribed you should
subscribe to longtime buddy of mine
about a week a week and a half ago John
Humphrey and I we test out a new segment
that we want to do called trailers
revisited what we basically do is we
look back at trailers from movies we've
already seen and we talked about like
does this trailer really spoil stuff how
accurate does this trailer really
represent the movie we tested it out
with a movie drive you want to start
with a smaller movie first so we could
see we didn't even do it yeah and people
responded really great to it so I
thought since Jordans visiting town from
Texas right now I thought it'd be fun to
do a new movie with him Black Panthers
coming out in a week so I said listen
let's do a Marvel movie one of the
Marvel recommended movies that we got a
few people said was Iron Man 3 you have
a Disney shirt on I do because it's
Disney yep I have a bat in hand I
actually kind of remember some of this
trailer yeah it'll be fun to revisit
yeah we all remember what Iron Man 3 was
yes
good life apologies to make
oh yeah this is not the tone at all and
super like super experienced things and
then they're over I can't sleep and what
I do I have nightmares
honestly just 100 people want to kill me
I hope I can protect the one thing they
can't live with that
[Music]
[Music]
some people call me a terrorist
I remember seeing this trailer and I was
like to do I hope the teacher
[Music]
it's a great trailer but does not
represent the town that line in the
movie
yeah
[Music]
so interesting how they cut this up
[Music]
this is just not the movie now this is
not the tone of the film at all this is
like like singing walk through the snow
and it's like that is so fascinating to
me to see this trailer because this
movie was straight-up a comedy this
isn't the same experience when I watch
the drive trailer because the drive
trailer is a horrible trailer the
difference with this one is this is a
great trailer yeah that totally
misrepresents the actual tone and style
of the film I didn't really enjoy I mean
man 3 I didn't well did it I did though
but I liked it a lot because I'm a huge
Shane black fan I was kind of expecting
that when I first heard he was signed on
then I saw this trailer and I was like
oh it's a little different than I was
expecting but then when I saw the movie
it was actually what I expected in the
first place I was really thrown off when
I saw the actual movie because I knew
Shane Black was doing it but I was like
I don't really know how much freedom
they're gonna give Shane boy yeah do
this movie and they let him just have
all the freedom freakin well yeah right
which is cool on that em but in terms of
looking at this trailer it has this
super serious somber tone it's weird
because all those elements are
technically in Iron Man 3 yes of him
having post-traumatic stress and the
fear of Pepper Potts dying and then
having to go up against the Mandarin all
that is technically all in the film it's
just the way it all is executed is it a
really zany fast-paced Shane black
comedy banter and even when he's dealing
with the stress and everything there's
still a lot of humor that comes from
that what the hell is that
your phone you surpassed me a big part
of this that I find really different is
this looks like an epic tragic tale yeah
what does it is not the Novi is not that
if any and he's not even Iron Man for
most of the movie he's just Tony Stark
yeah the rock the supermajority which is
why a lot of people didn't like now I
can see why people especially when you
see this trailer why people would be
disappointed without ya when you're like
this was the movie at all that I was
expecting to walk into you really
different and I think the other thing
that this trailer really builds up well
is the use of the Mandarin yes because
the Mandarin here has all these bitching
lines yeah Kingsley looks great this
looked like the film that we've been
wanting Iron Man to have huh where it's
the epic showdown between him and the
Mandarin so kudos to the trailer for not
spoiling a lot of big plot something
because no one saw what happens like no
one's yeah coming by the way spoiler
alert if you're a double right
absolutely no don't have a face when it
was revealed that he wasn't actually the
Mandarin that he's just an actor so many
people hated that I loved it I mean I
still want the Mandarin to get I think
they're shot and they go zero down the
road yeah but having Ben Kingsley his
character end up being just some random
dumb actor I thought that was so amazing
and it was like so Shane black - I like
that the second time I watched it I
think the first time I watched it I said
yeah I felt really cheated this is
actually because of what I saw yeah yeah
in terms of like epic slow mode tragic
this is the first serious Tony Stark
movie I've ever had that's not the case
at all a big part of what totally
misrepresents it is Tony Stark the last
shot of him walking in the snow
there's no music so quiet
big you said Batman begin yes it feels
like it's gonna have like that Nolan
type of tone to it yeah wow it's
actually pretty shocking it to go
because I seen the Iron Man 3 movie at
least three times
yes point I did go back and watch this
trailer yeah I remember thinking of
going into a completely different film
yeah I'm interested in going back and
like watching all of the Marvel trailers
now just to see what like how do ya are
the tone and everything from the actual
movie this is fascinating because I
think that now Marvel's much better at
accurately representing the tone and
style of their movies specific guardians
of the galaxy yeah man because I
remember the Thor trailer that was a
very serious trailer yeah it's not as
comedic as like an Iron Man 3 but
there's a lot of comedy in the work yeah
that is not represented a shot of water
comedy we don't have horses just dogs
cats birds they give me one of those
large enough to rock there's a lot of
comedy that people weren't expecting but
that's very much present in the Thor
movie and I remember the trailers doing
that too yes I think Iron Man 3 is
easily the most misrepresented one yeah
definitely it was the most unexpected
for sure because this is a great example
of audience anticipation versus the
actual product now we get this is just a
reaffirmation to me wow I remember being
really disappointed yeah good the second
time I watch it I was able to accept it
for what it is part of it I get like you
know showing Ben Kingsley as the
Mandarin and stuff to throw off
audiences from the big twist I get that
kind of like misleading them in that way
they still could have shown some of the
humor and stuff in